我知道
很多人一早起床
一定都要來一杯咖啡
覺得那是每天的開機儀式
不喝就醒不來
但你知道嗎
那杯咖啡其實正可能
悄悄毀掉你的提神力
因為在那個時間
你體內天然的提神激素
皮質醇
原本它應該幫你自然甦醒
集中注意力
結果卻被咖啡打亂節奏
久了以後
你會發現
不喝咖啡就更容易累
提不起勁
甚至一整天精神都不好
那這代表什麼呢
其實你身體可能正陷入一種
皮質醇日夜節律失衡的狀態
這不只是壓力大而已
還可能影響你的體重
情緒、膚況
甚至老化的速度
所以今天這支影片
我想帶你一步一步來去搞懂
皮質醇日夜節律到底是什麼
為什麼早上那杯咖啡會打亂它
節律亂掉的時候
身體又會出現哪些警訊呢
最後
我也會和大家來分享
我自己平常是怎麼紓壓
放鬆
讓身體自然充電的
如果你也常覺得累
腦袋卡卡
提不起動力
那這支影片會幫助你
重新找回真正的清醒力
在深入談皮質醇之前
我想先請你花一點時間
觀察一下自己最近身體的狀況
有沒有覺得臉好像比較浮腫
線條變得比較圓潤
早上起來照鏡子
感覺精神不太好
或是情緒比較容易起伏
脾氣大
甚至肌肉常常緊繃
痠痛
頭也跟著痛
或者是食慾突然變多
暴飲暴食
甚至完全沒胃口吃不下
那可能就代表你身體
其實已經開始失衡了
壓力荷爾蒙皮質醇
可能已經失去原本該有的節奏了
首先我先為大家說明
皮質醇是什麼
它是身體用來應對壓力的一個荷爾蒙
目的是產生支援
讓我們去應對壓力環境
比如說提高血糖
讓我們可以決定
我們是要逃跑或是戰鬥
那為什麼皮質醇會失衡呢
正常的皮質醇日夜節律又是怎樣的呢
一天的皮質醇變化應該是這樣的
早上起來後30分鐘
它會快速提升到最高點
這主要是為了幫助我們清醒
同時幫助我們提升我們的能量
隨著白天的進行
皮質醇會漸漸的下降
但在上午呢
它仍然會維持比較高的水平
支撐我們的專注力和工作的效率
到下午就會逐漸的下降
讓身體準備去放鬆
晚上降到一定程度的時候
我們就順利入睡了
最低點一般是發生在
入睡後的半夜的時間
會讓我們維持一個比較
深度的睡眠狀態
這樣的節律才能確保我們白天充滿活力
晚上又可以睡得香甜
但如果你的皮質醇是
該高的時候不高
該低的時候不低
那你可能就會有
早上爬不起來
白天沒精神
到了晚上卻亢奮的睡不著
這問題就出在於
我們皮質醇分泌的節奏已經跟
生活的節奏不同步了
如果說皮質醇水平長期失衡
不管是居高不下或者是過低
它都會對我們健康造成破壞性的影響
甚至讓人處於亞健康的狀態
久了當然也會帶來許多的疾病
如果你聽到這裡
覺得很多症狀都跟自己很像
先別擔心
我們整理了一份
皮質醇失衡自評表
讓你初步去檢視自己的節率
是否被打亂
也能更清楚下一步該怎麼調整
回到一開始我們提到的
那為什麼一早起床不能喝咖啡呢?
咖啡提神術是最多人愛用的
很多人一早起床就習慣喝咖啡
希望自己快一點醒來
但如果你皮質醇日夜節律
本來就不是太穩定
這杯咖啡不一定就是最佳的時機
因為我們身體本來有一套
自然醒來的節奏
起床後三、四十分鐘
皮質醇會自己上升到當天的高峰
這是一個很重要的覺醒反應
能讓你精神變清楚
血糖變穩定
也幫助身體進入白天的代謝狀態
咖啡因確實可以讓人覺得醒
但它的機制是阻斷腺苷這個睡意訊號
你的疲勞並沒有被解決
只是暫時被掩蓋
腺苷還在
它就會持續累積
等到咖啡因退掉
就會一起湧上
所以有一些人到下午會突然覺得很累
往往是這個原因
另外咖啡因本身
也會讓皮質醇在上升
如果這個刺激
剛好落在它原本就要上升的清晨
它會讓原本的高峰變得更高
也更久
原本應該要慢慢下降的節律
就會被延後
節律穩定的人來說
我們身體其實大多還能調整回來
但你如果本來就有那種
早上起來精神差
晚上睡不好
或一整天都提不起勁的問題
這種咖啡帶來額外的刺激
反而會讓整體的節律更亂
可能很多人就會問
難道早上是不能喝咖啡的
當然可以
只是不要在
剛醒來的第一個時間我們就喝
給身體一點時間
進入白天的狀態
等起床後大約一個半小時到兩個小時
這個時候再喝咖啡
會更穩定
更舒服
更能夠真正的提升精神
而不是讓能量
忽高忽低
所以關鍵只是調整這個時間點
讓咖啡成為加分
而不是一醒來
就靠它把身體拉起來
接下來我會帶你看看
當皮質醇真的失衡的時候
身體會發生什麼事
有些你以為只是壓力大
睡不好、變胖
其實都和皮質醇有關
身體對壓力的反應不是一成不變的
它是隨著時間慢慢的改變
其實很多研究都有發現
皮質醇的節律
會因為我們壓力的累積
生活的方式
疾病
年齡變化
呈現一種動態調整
逐步偏離的一個過程
最典型的變化就是
在身體剛開始進入
壓力環境的那個時間
我們整個系統通常是反應過強的
清晨的覺醒反應也會比較高
這時候皮質醇往往會因為刺激
升得比較快
也比較高
心跳莫名的容易快了起來
容易緊繃
也容易焦慮
在這樣的狀況下
晚上也容易睡不好
食慾也容易亂掉
對於高油、高糖的食物
也會變得比較渴望
這階段的狀況對生活來說
其實影響並不太大
但如果這個壓力環境沒有改變
皮質醇的日夜節律
自然會變的開始扭曲
清晨的高峰會變弱
白天下降得變得平緩
高峰和低谷之間差距也會縮小
整體起伏會變得不明顯
這時期的人往往早上會起不來
晚上會睡不好
開始也產生代謝失衡的問題
焦慮、煩躁、失眠
在女生的部分
也很容易遇到
經前症候群變嚴重
或者是月經不規則的這種現象
這樣的壓力環境持續下去
長期下來
有的人甚至會從反應過強
變得反應很弱
皮質醇的曲線會變得平平的
幾乎看不到高峰
簡單來說
皮質醇失調不是瞬間壞掉的事情
而是一個長期的拉長
拉扁、拉疲乏
最後生理系統在長期壓力之下
逐步被調整過的一個過程
這其實就是我們在功能醫學上
常說的一個
壓力適應的三階段的一個過程
一開始的警訊期
皮質醇的反應會變強
接著是抗性期
我們靠的是代償來去硬撐
那最後如果壓力一直存在的時候
就會進入匱乏期
我們反應力反而開始下降
整套系統開始變鈍
但讓這條皮質醇曲線開始走樣的
其實大多不是我們遇到了什麼重大事件
而是生活中一點一滴的累積
我們常常以為
壓力太大是心情的問題
但真正會讓皮質醇日夜節律失衡的
其實不只是心理壓力
還有生活裡那些
你根本不會把它當成壓力的事情
這些看起來不起眼的小事情
才是皮質醇日夜節律
最容易被拉亂的原因
像是睡不好
作息不規律
明明累得不行
卻還滑手機滑到半夜
那這時候皮質醇晚上降不下來
早上升不起來
節律自然被打亂
第二
過度勞累其實也會
身體明明就已經在喊了
說讓我休息一下吧
你卻還是把一整天都塞滿
從早忙到晚
那你皮質醇一路被推著跑
沒有真正下降的一個時間點
第三
血糖波動
也是很容易被忽略的壓力
我們現代人早餐往往亂吃
午餐可能又拖得太晚
下午就靠咖啡或手搖去硬撐
就蛋白質纖維吃不夠
那血糖就像雲霄飛車
這樣衝上去又掉下來
晚上我們又嘴饞吃個宵夜
這時候半夜的血糖又重新上升
壓力系統又必須重新啟動
第四
久坐
久坐更是現代人
低估的一個壓力來源
研究就指出
久坐的人
面對急性心理壓力的時候
皮質醇反應反而會更大
而且這跟平常是否運動
體脂肪多少都沒有關係
簡單來說
久坐就會把身體的壓力音量放大
同樣的壓力事件
活動量高的人
皮質醇一下就會掉回來
久坐的人卻會飆得更高
掉得更慢
第五
過度使用3C
也會讓大腦一直處於高負載狀態
不只是有藍光的問題
而是訊息太多
太快
大腦沒有真正放空的時間
我們皮質醇就很難回到穩定的節奏
當皮質醇日夜節律
真的長期失衡的時候
它影響的不只是我們的精神狀態
皮質醇其實是
身體維持穩定的一個調節總管
它的節奏一亂
牽動的就是整個系統的平衡
在代謝系統
皮質醇分泌過量會造成葡萄糖新生
推高血糖
造成胰島素阻抗
那你之後第二型糖尿病的風險
和代謝症候群的風險就會上升
在免疫系統
皮質醇具有免疫調節能力
長期不穩定
你免疫反應就會失控
所以很容易造成我們慢性發炎
或者說增加過敏的問題
或感染的問題
更不用說在性荷爾蒙的部分
雌激素、黃體酮
雄性素
或者抗衰老的DHEA
跟皮質醇其實都是
同一條原料路線上面的夥伴
所以皮質醇的波動
就會干擾到荷爾蒙的調節
最後在神經系統的部分
皮質醇日夜節律會影響我們的睡眠品質
壓力回饋和情緒的穩定
所以它也會增加我們的焦慮
情緒低落和認知能力下降的風險
因此如果你發現這種疲累不是一兩天
而是連續兩週以上都這樣
那往往不是單純的累
而是身體的壓力節律
真的開始亂掉了
這時候
我們可以透過壓力荷爾蒙的檢測
了解皮質醇的變化
越早找到問題越早調整
身體就越能回到正常節奏
假如大家有檢測的需求
也歡迎到初日診所
找我進一步評估喔
接下來我們分享幾個
可以把節律找回來的工具
首先第一個
讓身體真的停一下
深呼吸
冥想
或放慢節奏做事情
都能讓皮質醇下降
常練習冥想其實能夠降低
我們下午的皮質醇濃度
甚至長期的皮質醇指標
像是頭髮的皮質醇也會跟著改善
第二
調整晝夜節律
起床後我們盡量去接觸自然光
去曬曬太陽
睡前的一個小時
不要去滑手機
第三
喝咖啡的時間
前面就有提到
我們不要一早就喝
而是在起床後
一到兩個小時再喝
然後中午過後
就盡量不要再喝咖啡了
避免它去干擾你的睡眠
第四 讓自己動起來
早上的快走或跑步
能夠降低白天的皮質醇
晚上也會更容易進入深層睡眠
第五
適應源
我相信這個詞彙
是比較少人聽過的
但它在壓力的調節裡面
是一個很重要的概念
能夠提升我們身體的抗壓韌性
讓反應不過度
壓力過後也會比較快
回到平衡
這講的是一類植物
它的萃取物往往
可以幫助我們做這樣的調節
常見的成分
像是南非醉茄
人參、紅景天這些都是
最後我想跟大家分享一下
我自己調節壓力的方式
新竹初日診所
從開幕到現在大概是一年三個月的時間
每天忙碌的看診以外
其實還有很多錄影
和節目內容準備的需求
所以其實我生活其實
從開幕那天開始
就變得很不一樣
我原本以為自己可以一路扛下來的
但其實身體很誠實
我的睡眠時間慢慢變得很短
有時候其實不到五點人就醒來了
通勤前往新竹的路上
塞車的時候也會意識到自己
莫名的心跳就會加快
我看診的時候
跟我們個案在講話的時候
我會發現自己居然講得上氣
不接下氣
往往是因為我知道後面
可能還有很多看診的個案在那邊等待
結果反而那個焦躁的情緒
就影響到看診的品質
那在 2025 的上半年
我甚至連續兩次的重感冒
這在以前是很少見的事情
那時候我才真的知道
其實壓力已經在提醒我
它需要重新被看到了
從那時候我就開始
重新做我的生活調整
每天早上
我把之前已經因為忙碌而遺忘的
正念練習
把它撿回來
每天一起床
我就先做個十到三十分鐘的練習
讓自己在一天開始之前
先回到身體的專注裡面
那塞車的時候
我也不是在焦慮的想說
我什麼時候會抵達診所
而是讓自己能夠安靜的聽音樂
看窗外的風景
看診的時候
我也開始練習只專注在眼前這一位個案
那除此之外
我也把一些基礎的營養把它穩住
比如說我開始在
睡前規律補充鎂
那狀態比較不好的日子
我也會用一些南非醉茄
來幫助我調節壓力
除此之外
每天至少三十分鐘的運動
像是健身環、超慢跑
讓運動變得更有趣
然後也更多花樣更容易持續
生活裡每個片段其實都有它的意義
陪伴家人的時候就好好陪伴
週末我也開始留一段
完全不工作
時間給自己
慢慢的啊
我真的感覺到身體舒服了很多
就算在忙碌的看診日
我的心情也能夠維持在理想狀態
所以最近啊
我就逢人就講說
我越來越覺得我能夠舒服的
過好日子了
那我把這些經驗分享出來
是希望大家在面對生活的忙碌的時候
也能夠多一點方法
多一點理解
讓自己有空間去修復
今天的影片就到這邊囉
如果說你有壓力過大
疲勞相關問題的朋友
歡迎大家來診所找我聊聊
那還想聽我聊什麼主題
歡迎大家在下方留言告訴我
最後也別忘了
訂閱 按讚 還有分享
還有加入初日醫學官方的LINE
你將會得到更多健康資訊喔
另外
我們頻道的會員功能已經開通了
歡迎成為瘦粉
用行動支持我們
下次影片再見
掰掰